have you ever wondered why our Silla is
as evil a Shias once you've heard the
secrets behind the Little Mermaid you'll
understand why the sea witch is so angry
keep watching to discover Ursula's
fascinating past as Vanessa and her
major sibling issues you'll be shocked
[Music]
Ursula seems to be a sea witch with a
bad attitude in the Little Mermaid there
are plenty of reasons why she's out for
revenge against king triton and why she
used Ariel's voice in why she
transformed into Vanessa too we're
delving into all of this to give you a
look at the truth behind Ursula's tragic
backstory starting with her childhood
Ursula and King Triton did you know that
Ursula and King Triton are brother and
sister
an original draft of the 1989 movie
positioned the Paris siblings there was
an alternate opening scene with a long
version of the fathoms below song and in
that song the sailors explicitly talk
about Ursula being King Triton sister
Ron Clements the co-writer and
co-director of the movie explains why
the scene was cut they shortened the
opening simply because they wanted to
get into the story faster but by doing
so they lost the exposition that the sea
witch and the King are siblings
so that makes Ursula Ariel's aunt
however the film didn't make that link
clear in the end it's debatable as to
whether the idea was to kept as cannon
in the main franchise however there is
one place where that relationship did
get played out and that's in the stage
musical version of The Little Mermaid
which opened on Broadway in 2008 we
learned all about the siblings past in
the song I want the good times back
Ursula sings about how they were each
given equal shares of the sea when their
father presided passed away they were
also given a magical object each Triton
got the Trident and Ursula got the
nautilus shell they were meant to rule
together
however Triton banished his sister after
she used dark magic that helps explain
why she's so keen to wreak revenge on
Triton in the song she also shares her
plan to overthrow her brother and
reclaim the sea Ursula is going to use
Ariel who's described as the daughter
with the beautiful voice that she takes
for granted are
listings about how a woman doesn't know
how precious her voice is and tell she's
been silenced and so she plans to teach
both Arielle and Triton a lesson we've
got some more fascinating theories about
Ariel's voice coming up later so keep
watching but back to the stage musical
and another version of Ursula's tragic
backstory Seven Sisters when the revised
version of the stage show went on
national tour the song I want the good
times back was replaced with a new one
the new song was called daddy's little
angel and in this song we get a new
backstory for the sea witch Ursula was
the youngest of seven sisters they were
all beautiful except for her she sings
about how her father Poseidon found her
loathesome and disgusting while her
sisters were adored Ursula was ignored
he gave her a magic shell to ease his
guilt but Ursula used the magic shell to
get rid of all six of her sisters so
when her father passed earth LA as the
eldest became queen of the sea however
she also had a little brother
Triton when he came of age he took over
the kingdom and that's why Ursula wants
revenge on him I'll give her something
to celebrate soon enough she sings about
using Ariel to get to Triton just like
she used her sisters to get to her
father interestingly this back story
gives Ariel and Ursula a big thing in
common
they're both the youngest of seven
sisters so now we have a couple of
different backstories for Ursula are you
ready for another one
poor unfortunate soul Ursula sings a
song in the 1989 movie called poor
unfortunate souls it could hold a clue
about her past as Vanessa but we'll get
to that intriguing theory later for now
we're focusing on the Disney novel about
her backstory which took that phrase as
its title released in 2016 the book
called poor unfortunate soul a tale of
the sea which gave us yet another
version of Ursula's backstory in this
tale Ursula is the adopted daughter of a
human fisherman she grew up not knowing
about her powers or that she was King
Triton's long-lost sister however her
powers do get exposed and the people in
her village turn on her in a violent way
her adoptive father tries to stop them
but passes away in the process
understandably Ursula gets pretty upset
over the events grieving for her father
she tries to
the village but King Triton reveals
himself as her brother and takes her
home to his kingdom
however Triton thinks Ursula is an ugly
monster as an octopus so he doesn't
allow her to be around his subjects in
her octopus form
Triton's wife Queen Athena is the only
one who's kind to her but after Queen
Athena passes King Triton vanishes
Ursula to the unprotected waters
vanished and exiled so it's no surprise
that Ursula is all about plotting
revenge on her brother all three of
these backstories do have something in
common and that's the sibling
relationship between Ursula and Triton
however a sequel to the film gives us
yet another look at our SLOS past and it
doesn't necessarily match up Morgana in
the movie The Little Mermaid to return
to the sea we get introduced to Ursula's
younger sister Morgana
the direct-to-video sequel which was
released in the year 2000 shows us Ariel
and her daughter melody and this time
the villain position is filled by
Morgana
although Ursula doesn't actually appear
in the movie we do get a couple of
glimpses of her
we learned that Morgana has always been
jealous of her big sister and she's
tired of living in Ursula shadow we even
get to see Ursula in her childhood in a
deleted scene in fact it's a deleted
song called gonna get my wish although
it wasn't used the song was fully
animated and it we see how Morgana
wanted the approval of her mother she
sings about how she's always been
second-best
to Ursula and how she'll impress her
mother when she steals the Trident which
is where our Scylla failed we see Ursula
with a first-place trophy being praised
by their mother there is a way of tying
these back stories together Ursula and
King Triton could have been half
siblings sharing the same father but
different mothers whichever version you
believe is the most likely they all give
us an interesting insight into why
Ursula was as evil as she was and we
haven't even touched on Ursula's
possible past as Vanessa so let's dive
into that right now the Vanessa question
there's been a lot of chatter about why
our silly toes Vanessa as her human
alter-ego she didn't need to look any
particular way as she was enchanting
Erik so she didn't need to find her
looks appealing that begs the question
why Vanessa why not any other kind of
appearance
Ursula could have just made herself a
copy of Ariel or any other person for
that matter there are some really
interesting fan theories about it first
up let's examine Vanessa's similarities
with Ariel the two women have very
similar facial features
sure vanessa has dark hair compared to
Ariel's red mane
but their eyes noses and mouths are very
alike not exact copies but similar in a
way that an aunt and aneesa's features
might be alike their resemblance makes
perfect sense now that we know that
Triton and Ursula might very well be
siblings Ursula was Vanessa let's take
this a step further
perhaps Ursula didn't invent Vanessa's
looks out of thin air but actually based
them on herself and how she looked
previously the fangirl has come up with
a theory that Ursula originally looks
like Vanessa just without the legs and
she previously used that appearance up
on land just like Ariel looks like
herself when she turns from a mermaid to
a human that's right this isn't Ursula's
first foray out of the sea she was so
furious that her brother took away her
Oceanic powers that she sought control
elsewhere she put a spell on herself to
become human so that she could find a
position of power on land perhaps by
going after a king or a prince that
person could even have been Eric's dad
this would explain why she knows so much
about the preferences of men when it
comes to dating women in her song poor
unfortunate souls
Ursula displays her in-depth knowledge
of the human world on land
how did she learn the nuances of the
dating game because she took part in it
let's take a look at some of the songs
lyrics Ursula tells Ariel the men up
there don't like a lot of blabber they
think a girl who gossips is a bore get
on land it's much preferred for ladies
not to say a word and after all dear
what is the idle prattle for it makes
total sense that Ursula could only know
all of that because she'd been on land
herself before after all we've seen from
Ariel's ignorance that the merpeople
don't know much about the human world
she doesn't even know what a fork is
used for let alone the intricacies of
the dating game
our slick continues to show Ariel her
knowledge of the world above the sea by
singing they're not all that impressed
with conversation true gentlemen avoid
it when they can but they dote and swoon
and fawn on a lady who's withdrawn it's
she who holds her tongue who gets a man
now of course Ursula would say things
like that to get Ariel to give up her
voice but she certainly seems to have
first-hand knowledge of human
relationships all that suggests that she
wasn't just enchanting men to love her
when she first got her land's legs she
had to learn how to woo a man in the
human world and she might have given the
humans a lot of information about the
marking 'dom after all the sailors show
their in-depth knowledge of life under
the sea in the original fathoms below
song how could they have known about
King Triton and Ursula being related
perhaps she told them but obviously
something went awry and Ursula ended up
back in Atlantica perhaps she
transformed herself into an octopus
woman as she came back under the sea and
maybe the human saw that and that's why
they hung around the area
hunting mermaids Ursula knew Vanessa
there's another fan theory this time on
reddit's that Ursula based Vanessa's
looks on a human woman she once knew as
Ursula gave her human form a plausible
name congratulations my dear
she made it clear it was someone
specific and someone that she wanted to
walk in the footsteps of but she
wouldn't want to risk taking the form of
someone she might accidentally bump into
so she would have to base it on someone
who couldn't possibly show up therefore
Vanessa would have been a real person
that Ursula had met on land she could
have learned all about human life from
her but
that woman was no longer alive perhaps
at the hands of Ursula herself the berry
goes on suggests that the original
Vanessa was a survivor of a shipwreck
Ursula met her on a desert island and
planned to help her get back to the
mainland but then Ursula got concerned
that Vanessa would spill all of the
secrets about the underwater Kingdom
that Ursula had shared so she had to
sacrifice Vanessa for the good of her
people
- pretty intense theory rights but a
super fascinating one nonetheless
regardless of where Ursula got Vanessa's
looks from one thing's for sure
she used Ariel's voice when she took on
her human form and there's a theory
about that - Ariel's enchanted voice did
you ever wonder why Eric was so
enchanted by Ariel's voice perhaps it's
not just that it sounds beautiful but
that it actually is enchanted and that's
why Ursula took it from Ariel this is
another fan theory on reddit that were
totally into to understand this idea we
need to look into mermaid folklore it's
a common trope that mermaids use their
voices to lure sailors to the depths of
the ocean so it would make sense that
Ariel had this power - and she enchanted
Erik with her voice when she rescued him
so that's perhaps why Ursula wanted
Ariel's voice Ursula knows that Ariel
won't have the same enchanting power
over Erik without her voice we see the
power that the voice has over Erik when
Vanessa turns up on land he's willing to
marry her because of that voice alone as
soon as possible this adds a whole new
level of interest to Ariel and Erik's
relationship she doesn't realize that
she's enchanted him and it's not made
explicit to the viewer that their love
is based on enchantments
otherwise we would find it all kinds of
wrong that Erik falls in love with her
so there are u habits
Ursula's fascinating backstory which
part of her tragic tale do you think is
most likely weighed in with your opinion
in the comment section below thanks for
watching make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
we'll see you next time
[Music]